[Music]
hi everyone judge andrew napolitano here
for judging freedom today is monday
september 12
2022 it's about five o'clock in the
afternoon
here on the east coast of the united
states two o'clock in the afternoon on
the west coast
where our next guest and my dear friend
and our regular weekly medical expert dr
joel wallach is standing by today
to discuss
high blood pressure
and metabolic syndrome what they are how
you get it how it's been misdiagnosed by
the medical community
and how you can address it
by supplementing uh your diet dr wallach
always a pleasure my dear friend welcome
back to the show
well thank you your honor as you did a
fabulous job of explaining what
metabolic syndrome is
kenneth thank you enough for the
opportunity to share with your followers
uh because you are the man okay and you
have such credibility
and such connections your your uh
partnership with us
on judging health which is a website
that you created for our audience to
gain access
to the vitamins and supplements uh that
you have prepared for them
uh has enhanced our credibility and
we're deeply grateful so what is blood
high blood pressure other than your
blood pressure is too high what causes
it what is metabolic syndrome and why
has it been misdiagnosed
okay well metabolic syndrome
uh came on the human population
after the advent of electricity
when we went from
uh using wood and coal as fuel
and had to deal with the ashes
the ashes of course we put into the
garden and they were like 98 minerals
and two or three percent carbon and
those for both the wood ashes and the
the um ashes from coal
and at three o'clock in the afternoon
your honor three o'clock in the
afternoon monday september 4th 1882 on
pearl street in new york city in the
bluff overlooking the construction of
brooklyn bridge thomas edison pulled the
switch on the first commercial electric
generating plant
within 18 years we were we were in big
trouble
by the year 1900 the obesity rate was
just skyrocketing
and
doctors would say stop eating animal fat
eat more whole grains and then they
started eating gluten more wheat by the
right oats and made it even worse
because the gluten was damaging the
intestines they couldn't absorb minerals
where they weren't getting minerals
anyway because they weren't getting the
wood ashes anymore and so they got a
double hit
and so that's basically the beginning of
this and after a while
there's one new disease after the other
and doctors combined obesity diabetes
and high blood pressure those three
things in what they call the metabolic
syndrome
and they blamed it on people's genes
that's your genes doing that okay your
bad genes okay blamed it on the patient
because they didn't know how to deal
with it
and um right now
um the metabolic syndrome was still
going crazy um
of americans are obese
18 are severely obese 43 of males
are
in the obese range 41.9 of females
obesity is defined as over 25 percent of
your ideal weight for your height and
age
okay
and the cause of obesity
uh in the metabolic syndrome is just
simple nutritional deficiency diseases
causing a behavior called pica
pica
um is people you know would say i'm just
hungry all the time
i have these cravings you know like
pregnant women would say oh man i crave
this i have to eat two pints of ice
cream every hour i'm craving it well
that's because she was deficient in
minerals and her body's saying eat stuff
find those minerals and so that's where
that
uh kind of behavior came from all right
let's focus on high blood pressure okay
what important is high blood pressure
how dangerous is it and what's the best
way to alleviate it
okay well high blood pressure
you know is where your blood pressure is
higher than clinically
acceptable okay clinically acceptable
wants your blood pressure to be
something like
um
80 over 50
kind of thing that's what i like is 80
over 50
um
and some people on mine i because you
know i'm athletic my my blood pressure
goes like
60 over 40 which is okay
okay
and so you know when you get over 100
110 you're in the high blood pressure
range even some people would be
defined as high blood pressure over 90.
they're at the top number over 90. 90
over 70 that would be high blood
pressure
and so
what does that mean does that mean that
the heart
is pushing the blood
through the arteries and veins with more
pressure is it literally pressure or is
that just a term that the medical
community uses
no that's the term the medical
um group uses but you have to appreciate
your blood system is a closed system
right okay it's not open on any end to
let stuff in it's not open on the other
end to let stuff out it's kind of a
circular system and the heart
is in the middle of it i'm pumping
the oxygenated
blood to other parts of the body
and by pressure from the heart pushing
the oxygen blood into the arteries the
veins are passively bringing back
the blood that doesn't have much oxygen
and the pressure's lower so that's the
circuit
okay
and
um
every mammal of course has the same
um system
heart
and when when you get blocked arteries
you begin to have really problems
because as you have blocked arteries
your heart's working harder and harder
and harder because your body's calling
for the oxygen hey hey don't forget me
and so your heart begins to pump harder
and you get congestive heart failure the
heart gets bigger because it's working
so hard
and it becomes inefficient because the
blood vessels are getting clogged
as well
not by cholesterol
that was a big mistake the doctors made
they falsely believed that cholesterol
was what was clogging your arteries no
that's not true what was clogging your
arteries
was the um
cooking with oils
oxidized oils that kind of stuff salad
dressings that's what was causing the
problems with clogged arteries
and once you know once they came up with
statin drugs to lower cholesterol we
really got into trouble
um cholesterol makes up 25 of the brain
weight
cholesterol makes up 25 of the spinal
cord weight
cholesterol makes up 95 of the weight of
testosterone cholesterol makes up 95 of
the weight of estrogen
so it's a very important substance
it's called myelin it's a white matter
of the brain
let's get back to let's get back to high
blood pressure why do some people have
it and some don't
okay
well people who eat more correctly okay
don't get high blood pressure staying
away from the fried foods the oxidized
oils and that kind of stuff so they're
not getting damage done it's kind of
like the the biological equivalent of
rust where oxygen is rusting iron
okay
and when you get oxidized oils it causes
inflammation on the lining of your
arteries you put scar tissue in there to
try and protect yourself and that's what
causes blockages of the arteries and
once the block of the arteries occur the
pressure goes up because the heart has
to work much harder to get that blood
flowing past the blockages
okay so what what does the medical
community
uh do about that and what do you say
should be done about that okay well the
medical community says oh this is a
genetic thing
you know your parents had it somebody in
your family had they passed it on to you
or it's an autoimmune thing your body's
attacking itself
and i can give you drugs to lower your
cholesterol i can give you drugs to
lower your blood pressure
but you'll be on these drugs forever
oh
i think we lost you
did you lose me i know you're back now
okay last thing the last thing yeah
you'll be on these drugs forever
okay and say and they tell you you'll be
on these drugs forever you know we get
people who are on these drugs for 25 30
40 years and then they die because they
really haven't solved the problem
uh and of course
um we like to
um have people eat three eggs twice a
day so they're getting cholesterol we
want them to get cholesterol so they
don't have this problem
and then
we want them to use our uh in addition
to the 90th century nutrients in
addition to
the
um
the healthy brain and heart pack okay
the 90 cents of nutrients which
everything including your heart needs
it's actually in the title of
the name of the
of the the food supplement the healthy
brain and heart pack
once you have that you also need to have
the the arteries dilate and open up and
allow the blood to flow through it so we
have what we call the healthy
excuse me the ultimate daily classic
tablets ultimate daily classic tablets
and they'll support healthy blood flow
through blocked arteries
and i take three of those twice a day
everybody should be taking three of
those twice a day i only weigh 142.
and
it's one of those things between the
ultimate daily classic tablets the
healthy brain and heart pack
uh also the msm which is for the
collagen and the walls of the arteries
and the valves and the heart and so on
so so you're you're
telling us
that the supplements that you have uh
put together
will relax the pressure in the arteries
and
open them up and allow the brain allow
the heart to operate at its normal rate
and the result is a reduction in blood
pressure
that's correct you get a reduction in
blood pressure
and um
uh it's one of those things where
it freaks the medical community out
because they can't believe it because
they get taught in school it's a genetic
thing
all right so
folks who want to go to
judginghealth.com
should get the
healthy body packs which you can see
right there
yeah they should get the healthy heart
well there's two packs two main packs
the healthy start pack which is this
basic one
okay and then we have the healthy brain
and heart pack which is the big one and
the healthy brain heart pack
has 215 nutrients in it the healthy
start pack has 90 the basics
got it
okay
how many people uh in america are stuck
taking uh drugs which are not which are
going to mask
the symptoms
of high blood pressure but not cure it
okay if they're not on
the youngevity system the other branded
heart pack and the ultimate daily
classic tablets
they're going the wrong direction okay
and so we're talking about
of americans are susceptible to high
blood pressure and blocked arteries
75 of americans
people who become vegetarians think well
if i become a vegetarian and don't eat
cholesterol i won't have those problems
but they get blocked arteries and they
get high pressure
yeah we lost you there you go now you're
okay
last thing we heard you say
was that um
vegetarians
get high
blood pressure as well that's correct
because they fry vegetables
they use oils for cooking
and they use oils for salad dressing
which oxidize so they're still getting
damaged the arteries but they think
since they've given up red meat and
given up
animal fat they're giving up cholesterol
and they still believe the doctor's
misinterpretation
that the clogged arteries are caused by
cholesterol consumption that's not true
now what about metabolic syndrome that's
high blood pressure obesity
and one diabetes
and diabetes okay we have discussed
obesity
uh and uh and diabetes as well yeah
exactly they're both easily resolved and
so our program is the healthy brain and
hard pack you take the
uh healthy brain and heart pack you also
take the um
um let's see here the msm
you take for the connective
tissue and the arteries and veins and so
forth you're also going to take
the
uh sweeties for the diabetes and you're
going to take the ultimate daily classic
for the high blood pressure you're going
to take the keto shake one meal a day
it's a meal replacer the keto shake and
you'll lose a half a pound of two pounds
a day so get rid of the obesity you'll
get rid of the high blood pressure and
you'll get rid of the diabetes
none of them are genetic men are
autoimmune
all three are easily gotten rid of
which freaks doctors out because they
don't believe it
doctor you've been freaking doctors out
for your entire career and you've been
helping your patients along so my dear
judging
freedom friends you can go to judging
health and you can get all these
materials
uh and if you need some help you can
obviously get some folks there who know
exactly what dr wallach's products are
and help you uh customize themselves for
you dr joe wallach always a pleasure
we'll pick a topic
uh and we'll have you explain it for us
next week just like you do here every
week well thank you so much your honor
you're an angel of god i cannot tell you
how
judge napolitano for judging freedom
[Music]
you